all right Chris
where are you from Russian where'd you
grow up
I was born in Los Angeles California
Inglewood uh but whenever I talk about
it I say that I grew up in Denver
Colorado
why is that well
born in La I left maybe when I was five
years old six years old
it's hard to kind of put the pieces
together at this point but uh going into
the details of the story a little bit uh
once I was born we I was born addicted
to heroin first and foremost and my
parents were living with their you know
my grandparents and um it was very
short-lived we by the time I was five
years old I flew out of a vehicle and I
broke my neck and smashed a big chunk of
my skull out and when I was hell of act
to the hospital my father
I guess he got away or he was
temporarily held and within three weeks
I was taken out of the hospital by my
father and we moved to Denver so I
consider my hometown Denver Colorado
because of that early move I'm afraid to
ask now what tell me what was your
childhood like
uh childhood you know I for lack of
better words it was it was [__] chaos
it was absolutely
crazy from day one as I just mentioned
alluded to before I you know I was born
addicted to heroin obviously I don't
remember what that was like my mother
was actively using when
uh she was pregnant with me and the
first couple years in LA in Los Angeles
were kind of a blur to me the only thing
that I I do remember is that moment that
I slipped out of that vehicle uh we were
driving a pickup truck and my parents
were both
you know drugged up while while they
were driving and I saw it as a little
kid it would be a good idea to reach
into the back uh outside the window
where our dog was Tyson and in the
process of putting my arm out I flew out
of the the window on I-5 and smashed my
head against the highway
and um hell you know helicopter ended up
picking me up you know ambulance came
and I do vividly remember a lady
stopping you know in a jeep saying hey
are you okay and even as a kid I kind of
thought to myself wow what a weird
[__] question to ask somebody who
just flew out of a vehicle
um so from there going to the hospital I
was taken out prematurely and I later
learned from my mother's brother so my
uncle that uh he cut I guess technically
kidnapped me out of the hospital because
he didn't want to go to prison and we
moved to Denver Colorado
and in Denver Colorado things just got
tremendously worse I mean it was
between abuse my dad was in a biker gang
and you know he had a big as much as I
hate to admit this and and embarrassing
as this is a big swastika tattooed on
his chest and was just attracted so much
hate so much trauma into our lives
um you know I watched my dad get shot in
the chest because of a gang-related
incident
um you know they were back and forth to
the methadone clinic and the friends
that would come over would abuse us you
know uh physically there were sexual
abuse at times and it was just a really
it was a very difficult uh
seven or eight years that we live my
brother and I I do have a brother as
well and it was crazy I mean in 1995 I
watched my mom die so it was it was
early in the morning we woke up and uh
they were at the methadone clinic they
would they were going at I don't know
six o'clock
and my brother and I walked you know
woke up walked into the living room they
just got back from the methadone clinic
and everything was normal and next thing
we knew my mom's face was blue purple
and blue my brother went outside and
dialed 9-1-1 and that was it you know
people were running around in the house
some guy was smacking my mom on the face
to wake her up because there was people
doing drugs in there and it was just uh
that's just an image that I'll never be
able to
uh get out of my head you know
and two years later my dad died he
committed suicide
um from drugs a deadly mixture of drugs
and at this point I was in New Jersey I
was very fortunate that I had met
at the time we would be my Guardians and
I was living with them temporarily while
my dad got his [__] together basically
and during that time they kind of pulled
me into the living room and said hey
your dad
you know he's he's dead you know so it
was just a I didn't get to talk to him I
didn't get to go to a funeral it was
just all very kind of instantaneous and
I got back to my my normal life
and that's kind of the breakdown of the
childhood I mean a lot happened in
between there there was a lot of drugs
there was a lot of abuse a lot of moving
foster care uh you know we went back and
forth a couple times to California
and
to sum it up that's kind of the trauma
side of the childhood
you graduated high school
so yeah I did I so at the age of well in
1998 I was in New Jersey
um I ended up going to school in New
Jersey with my Guardians uh my brother
ended up moving back to California to be
with my dad's sister and I ended up
graduating high school education was
extremely difficult for me I I failed
classes I felt uh really like a piece of
[__] in school because I didn't go to
school when I was with my parents we
were running around the city we were you
know CPS was chasing us around so I was
really insecure about high school
um in education in general but I did
finally graduate in 2005. and today I
mean I I'm very passionate about
education today I have a bachelor's I'm
going to have you know hopefully Masters
soon and uh it's something that I'm very
passionate about today but education is
really hard for me it always has been so
your story is very different than the
majority of other other
stories where they had upbringings
kind of similar to yours yeah because
you did not get into all the crazy drugs
and
self-destructive behaviors right it's
you know
I wake up in the morning sometimes and I
wonder
like how am I live today right I mean
it's just
it's hard to contemplate how I got to
this point you know because if people
look at me today I'm just a business
part I'm really successful in in Tech
and I've got a great uh career a great
family
I did go through trial and tribulation
with drugs in high school right I did
some drugs and I I experienced all that
because during that time mentally it was
hard for me because I thought that's
what I was because that's what I saw
from my parents right I was very and I
always say this now I feel like I'm very
fortunate and I'm
I'm
resilient and I can I can get away from
the thought of doing you know drugs and
I've been very dedicated to not doing
that stuff so yes I mean to your point
I'm a very rare example I in at least in
my opinion of somebody who's made it to
this point who's built success or is
alive frankly or isn't in prison uh yeah
I mean I think my what do they say I
think my lucky stars every day right I
mean there's definitely in my mind
there's a higher power you know there's
no there's no doubting it have there
been any rough patches in your adult
life that uh
maybe you're an aftermath of that yeah I
mean you know most of my struggles today
are
Centric around mental health and how I
process things it wasn't until I was in
my early 30s that I figured out that
I had PTSD and I experienced a lot of
the symptoms of it disassociation and
you know derealization some of these
things I didn't know anything about
because I never had support figuring it
out
um so yeah I mean today I'm much
stronger I have a lot more
self-awareness and emotional
intelligence and I understand what I'm
going through today
but through my 20s I did I had a lot of
rough patches I would quit jobs you know
I didn't feel like I was worth being
successful I would sabotage
relationships I would treat people like
you know trash because I wanted to keep
them out of my life uh and to me it just
all seemed normal
and none of it was normal right so and
today I know that of course but
you know so I I still have struggles
today I mean you know more mentally
emotionally processing things uh but I
have tools today to manage it which is
the difference have you seen therapy
therapist
yeah I see I do see therapists still I
see a therapists once a week uh you know
I think therapy talk therapy is really
important I think it's really important
to articulate you know what's going
through your mind whether that be
through talk therapy or through you know
friends or you know some kind of
Professional Service right so I do I
believe in it but I didn't for a really
long time because I just kind of thought
I was going insane and didn't think that
talking to somebody could help you know
and you know today I take medication as
well you know it's like Zoloft or if you
antidepressants I was a huge
wildly against them for a long time and
I'm not really sure why to be honest
with you but they've changed my life you
know so I I have the tools now I feel
like I'm more stable to be
talking about how I feel and more
productive and you know support my
family and
kind of move forward in a positive way
in my life
did you ever feel loved when you were a
kid
no I I as a kid I really didn't feel
like there was support I didn't feel
like
there I felt like what I was going
through was normal as weird as that
sounds I felt like seeing all of this
chaos and moving constantly and seeing
you know the biker gang people show up
and the drugs and I thought all that was
normal but I never got the impression
that
I was really supported as a kid and I
didn't at the time realized that that
wasn't normal right so
I would say all in all I I didn't feel
supported and you know we were kind of
running the streets as a kid in
what I've learned today is it's just
built tremendous survival mode for me
right and I was in survival mode I look
at my son today who is seven years old
and I think my kids seven
and when I was seven years old I'd
already broken my neck falling out of a
truck I was trying to find food on the
streets of Denver
and I can't imagine what it would be
like for my son who gets upset if I'm
not there for five minutes to go through
that right so
having a kid is kind of a reflection I
look at myself and I think wow like my
parents
really just didn't give a [__] about
what was going on and
that's tough to swallow man like that's
that's a hard pill to swallow
you know and not to say that they didn't
love me
you know because I'm sure you know
addiction's crazy right I mean obviously
I've I've accepted what has happened and
I'm empathetic at this point but it's
it's still hard to say yeah so today you
you have a partner and you you have a
child I do I have a wife uh we've been
together almost 15 years and I have a
seven-year-old and we live in just a
nice little kind of rural town in
Pennsylvania
um and I just try to live a really quiet
life today and and you know I still talk
to my obviously my adopted mom who later
on adopted me you know which I'm very
fortunate for uh so yeah I feel like
today is just a lot more normal than
it was you know 20 years ago or 25 years
ago where do you think you get the
capacity to live a a normal life now
given the child that you had yeah it's
one of the things that
I've spent a lot of time and energy on
is
figuring out the things that are going
through my head and one of my biggest
issues has always been intrusive
thoughts I always you know for many
years I would think about just horrible
things right and I just thought I was
going crazy and I've invested a lot of
time money and energy into understanding
my feelings if that makes sense so I
think the fact that
I'm invested in myself today is allowing
me to live a normal life and when things
do come up when I get into depression or
I have anxiety or I go into
disassociation from PTSD you know my
body gets real shaky I understand it
today which allows me
to not solve the problem but I can deal
with it and I can deal with it in a
productive way and outside of that I
just think I'm really lucky maybe you
know biologically chemically
you know something in my brain has been
shaped or molded to be more effective
maybe than some other people and I'm
very fortunate for that today
do you see any like self-destructive
behaviors or anything like that stemming
from what you went through as a kid yeah
I mean I I don't have any you know like
physical you know self-destructive
um I never hurt myself I never thought
about hurting myself but I have you know
in the past have been really
self-destructive with my success and
with my relationships and my emotions
um
you know figuring out you know this what
do they call it uh
there's a the syndrome imposter syndrome
and things like where you just feel like
you're not worth enough for what you're
getting and that's been really tough for
me because I came from literally living
in a [__] rat nest
[__] heroin house to being a really
successful you know technology sales
person that's been selling to the
government for 18 16 years right and
there's a lot of days I wake up and I'm
like wow this is not normal you know I
need to I need to leave my job and
go back to what I'm supposed to be
that's the hardest part for me today
so your biological dad was a biker with
the swastika tattoo and your mom was a
heroin addict yeah use your biological
parents do you see any kind of
hereditary traits that you might have
from them
um because you seem pretty straight
laced right now no there's not really a
lot that I can relate with them on I
mean if anything to be honest one thing
that especially the racism aspect of it
has taught me I'm almost grateful that
he lived that life because it taught me
just how [__] sour it is right and
how bad it was and how negative it is to
hate other people for no better reason
than their African-American or Asian or
whatever it is you know I hate to say
that I'm grateful for that but it taught
me so much today right and I've been
able to get involved in different ways
you know with non-profits and I'm more
passionate about it but I will say that
I look back like at my mom and my mom
was a very calm and Collective person
despite being you know a heroin addict
and
you know not fully there and I do feel
like I have some of her more kind of
laid back and you know more decisive
traits that she had even though she
couldn't kick the struggle with drugs
but outside of that no I mean I I have
completely disconnected myself from my
biological parents and I don't want to
have those traits right I mean if
anything I've just learned from it and
that's it and hopefully it'll just stay
that way
what was your favorite memory as a kid
man that's a that's a really tough one
because there was just so many terrible
ones
um what was your worst memory as a kid
maybe that's a bigger question yeah I
mean I'll give both I mean I think some
of the worst
some of this is just really hard to talk
to to say
um
one of the worst memories I have is
actually like a sexual assault situation
uh where we were living next door
to a predator and uh we were you know my
parents were partying in our little
apartment it was on Cherokee Street in
Denver Colorado
and the people next door were partying
in this weekend and one of the kids was
18 or 19 said hey come over we're you
know we're having a party or whatever
and so my brother and I young kind of
naive walked in and next thing we knew
like the door was shut in this little
apartment that they were in and the kid
pulled out a knife and you know I don't
want to like get into the weeds of what
transpired but that's like a
that was probably one of the worst
experiences uh
that I've ever that I can recall that I
that I just think about and I still kind
of have that image burn in my head you
know
um
and from there my dad you know we ran
out
shortly thereafter and my dad went
downstairs like we had a little basement
he grabbed a gun you know your dad found
out oh yeah we I we went over
and fortunately I didn't go as far you
know it we were able to get out before
it got really bad and we went I said to
my dad I was like hey you know this guy
is trying to molest us basically and he
went downstairs he grabbed a gun and the
kid ran out and
all I know is you know my brother and I
walked out he was chasing him down the
street just you know blowing rounds off
at him and it you know he went he ended
up going to jail my dad ended up going
to jail for I want to say three or four
weeks because of that and I to this day
I have no idea what happened to that guy
and it's just you know so there was
really no closure there right I mean
it's is he still around is he not around
um just a really horrible
horrible situation all around
um you know and I you know for the best
I think
as a kid who had nothing
and
was really just trying to figure out
what the next day was going to look like
some of the best memories I have is you
know as [__] up as it sounds are you
know my brother and I who I'm still very
close with today he's older younger he's
a year older than me he lives in
California how's he doing uh he's doing
good I mean he you know we live
completely different lives
um but he's he he's doing good but he's
not into drugs or anything like that
he's not into drugs he may you know he's
got a daughter
um he's out in California Northern
California and it's great you know we
still talk to this day
and you know the best memories I have
and I'm sure my brother will appreciate
hearing this is you know just him and I
going out together to the park right
right there in on Capitol Hill in Denver
and going to the churches at like five
six seven years old to pick up
sandwiches because we were hungry right
and that's I think about that and I
think about him and I just kind of
walking together having that Bond of
survival and it just calms me down I
mean it's just such a warming feeling to
know that we had each other right and I
can't even imagine what I would have
done had I not had a sibling you're an
only child who had been really tough on
you to go through that and we still have
a you know we're much different people
today but we'll never lose that Bond
right I mean it's will never lose the
bond that we have because of that
and Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
man the most important lesson I
to this you know as I sit here today at
you know 36 years old and reflect just
kind of on my entire life and being
one of the biggest lessons that I still
think about
today is just the importance
of seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel if that makes sense and just
yeah there's been so many times hope
right
there's been so many times that
I've gotten to the point where I'm like
man like is it really worth being here
you know
um
and I just felt so dark and
just that one tiny bit of hope that I
had one tiny bit that okay someday
I can have a family I'm gonna get
through this right this dark phase of
misery in my head where I feel guilty
about everything or whatever it is the
symptoms of the depression
the the PTSD whatever the [__] it is
that I'm feeling many times I don't even
know that's part of the issue
just that little glimmer like I'm gonna
get through this at some point and
that I attribute to me just being alive
today and just kind of sticking through
it and
fighting through whatever it is I'm
going through and I
am so grateful that I've been able to do
that and I don't think enough people
have that ability because there's just
so much there's such a lack of support
and resource to people who go through
that I mean you walk past a homeless
person on the street they're asking for
money you know get the [__] away from me
right like you don't know what the story
is so it there's just this natural
desire that we've built as a society to
just kind of disregard that disregard
those people and I don't know how I came
through that
but I did and you know I hope as a
society we change that someday
honestly
we talk Chris thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for having
me I appreciate it I'm glad you've
survived and uh thrived I I am too and
and you know I for anybody who needs
just a little glimmer of hope you know
just
cliche as it sounds it does get better
so all right thank you very much thanks